this episode was made in collaboration
with azure scapegoat
they run a fantastic channel covering
all sorts of leftist topics so be sure
to check out their video after this
[Music]
this is marxism and marxism is based on
the belief that no person has any value
as an individual i believe i was
one of the first commentators to point
out that it was a very marxist
movement and the organization is part of
a global
movement to destroy life as we know it
in america
and probably in the rest of the western
world
they're just bad i believe in free
enterprise they're marxists
i believe in equal opportunity they
believe in government guaranteed equal
outcome we will
honor your courage with my
administration's determination to defeat
communism and socialism and we will do
that in our own country too we're in the
process of doing it right now
the courageous veterans here today bear
witness to how socialism radical mobs
and violent communists
ruin a nation if there's one thing
america has down to a science it's
twisting the meaning of words and using
them to terrify the population
ever since the soviet union rose to
prominence to the point of competing
with the us for global supremacy
the powers that be have fought hard to
burn the image of communism and
socialism as great evils into the mind
of the average american
in this episode we're going to correct
the record there's nothing wrong with
criticizing ideas you disagree with
but in order to do that you have to
engage with accurate depictions of those
ideas
so let's talk about america's favorite
boogeyman marxism
but before we do that we need to briefly
discuss the history of capitalism
once upon a time there existed an
economic system that was neither
capitalism
nor communism shocking right under this
arrangement
lords granted parcels of land to the
lower echelons of society
and the recipients known as vassals in
exchange would work the land and vow to
fight for their lord should he call upon
them
this was a pretty sweet deal for the
nobility because they got laborers to
work their land grow them food and fight
in their wars
the vassals had little choice other than
to enter into these agreements in order
to stave off starvation and abject
poverty
this type of arrangement later became
known as feudalism and from a modern
perspective
it seems outdated and cruel fast forward
several centuries and we begin to see a
fledgling new economic system take its
first steps
somewhere between the 14th and 15th
centuries feudalism lost ground to a
market-based system
one that elevated some of the lower
tiers of society creating a new merchant
class
not quite peasant but certainly not
nobility since that time
various interpretations of market-based
economies have been implemented with
varying degrees of success around the
world
when proponents of capitalism say that
it raised the standard of living for
millions of people
they're correct capitalism has its place
in history and has
unquestionably increased global
production many times over since the
days of feudalism
but just like technology keeps advancing
so too does history need to keep moving
and just like feudalism was overtaken
when it became outdated
so too will capitalism need to be
replaced with a superior system
we have a tendency to believe that
history is only something that happened
in the past
that we've now reached the end of
history this perspective makes it
difficult to see that life and progress
are ongoing processes and that there
will come a time when capitalism will
seem just as outdated as feudalism
i believe we're at a point where large
portions of the world population are
beginning to realize that global
capitalism is actively making their
lives worse
the system having generated such vast
oceans of capital in the hands of the
powerful that it's left the majority to
suffer needlessly
even in tremendously wealthy countries
this inflection point the shift in
public perception to viewing capitalism
less than favorably
signals the beginning of a massive
societal change capitalism is falling
out of favor
just as feudalism did those hundreds of
years ago so
what exactly is wrong with capitalism
this is the part where you may have to
grit your teeth and sit through some
things you don't want to hear
in america we've gotten our
self-identity so wrapped up in our
economic system that we see capitalism
and america as the same thing
capitalism is our national identity and
therefore any criticism of capitalism is
an attack on the nation itself
this should not be the case an economic
system is just one way to structure the
monetary relations of a country
it's not a national culture capitalism
is a tool
which in theory should elevate the
people of said country and materially
improve their lives
let's look at some examples of why this
is no longer the case we'll start with
the most obvious problem
the massive discrepancy between worker
and executive compensation and power
your paycheck isn't actually based on
how good a job you do
not really your boss is in a position of
power where he chooses which people to
hire and which to
fire the people that work for him
produce goods or services which then
become his property and which he then
sells to make a profit
your paycheck is in reality determined
by your minimum needs and your boss's
requirements for labor power in the
relation to the number of people
competing for jobs
the more people who are unemployed that
is the more people who are looking for
jobs
the easier it is for companies to hire
desperate poor people for minimum wage
in this way unemployment in society is
actually beneficial for capitalists
and having a large reserve of people
ready to step in and work for minimum
wage means that the average employee is
always living in fear of losing their
job
if you make a fuss if you complain if
you try to get a union involved
there is always someone to take your
place to the capitalist
you are expendable just another cog in
the machine to be replaced at their
convenience
it is in your boss's interest to make
your paycheck as small as possible
while increasing the prices of goods and
services this maximizes profits for him
but forces you to tighten your belt when
your boss pays you crumbs compared to
what you could be making and your
landlord raises your rent
that leaves you with a lower quality of
life and less financial mobility
this all works out beautifully for the
owner class their profits increase year
after year
there is however a flaw in this system
well you know besides the blatant
disregard for human life
unemployed and poorly paid workers don't
make for a profitable market
when workers are paid so little that
they can barely afford rent how could we
expect them to buy goods and services on
the market
companies produce more and more consumer
products but what happens when the
consumers can no longer afford the very
goods their labor produces
this creates a snowball effect low wages
and precarity lead to an unprofitable
market
an unprofitable market means that the
production of consumer goods is limited
which inevitably leads to economic
depression have you ever noticed how
there seems to be an economic crisis
like once every 10 years
well that's actually not by accident
these crises have been happening ever
since the very beginning of capitalism
this upward and downward motion of the
market is known as the business cycle
boom and bust yoyoing from one extreme
to the other every decade or so
the boom comes from accumulation of
wealth when prices go up and wages go
down
companies make money but if the people
are squeezed too hard and the market
becomes unprofitable
it then leads to a depression businesses
close people lose their jobs debts
aren't paid banks collapse
governments run out of money that's an
economic crisis
and they're just gonna keep coming even
though every one of them will be dressed
up as once in a lifetime and sure to
never happen again
just like we heard in 2008 and just like
we heard during the corona crash
which not to be overly pessimistic is
only a teaser for what we'll see in the
next couple years
don't be fooled capitalism is unstable
by its very nature
the system encourages greed and because
of this capitalism will always shoot
itself in the foot in the name of
short-term gains over long-term
stability
just look at the financial crisis of
2008 the largest upward transfer of
wealth in modern american history
until the coveted pandemic of course in
short the stock market crash was caused
because predatory institutions became
too greedy
they began offering unstable housing
loans to people who would not have
normally qualified
this led to millions of people taking on
loans that would implode and that they
would be unable to pay back
housing prices went up creating what's
known as a speculative real estate
bubble
and as bubbles do it burst triggering
the single largest single day stock
market drop in history
up until that point millions of
americans lost their homes
their jobs their health care and many of
them never recovered from the financial
devastation
in the wake of the millions of evictions
and foreclosures huge corporate real
estate firms and banks snapped up the
empty houses at bargain bin prices
and many of them are held captive on the
rental market to this day
in the end the average american bore the
brunt of the fallout
and the executives and capitalists
behind the disaster got off scot-free
the housing crash is a huge complicated
topic and i would encourage you to read
more about it but the most important
thing to realize is that what should
have been a completely avoidable
catastrophe was inevitable because of
our rabid devotion to ever-increasing
profits
we've seen a similar occurrence since
the beginning of the pandemic the
richest people in the country have
increased their wealth at a staggering
rate
while average americans have again lost
their livelihoods and their health care
which is a pretty bad thing to lose in
the middle of a plague
but since providing our citizens with
universal health care isn't profitable
to insurance companies
our health care is tied to our
employment when we lose our job
we also lose our right to live in the
eyes of our corporate overlords
to them a human life has no value except
what profits can be extracted from it
this isn't due to some inherent evil in
every corporate executive
it's simply a byproduct of capitalism
capitalists are very much conditioned
into being cruel because cutting wages
and other actions harmful to workers
rewards them with greater profits
and giving their workers benefits like
maternity leave punishes them with
reduced profits
even otherwise good people are affected
by this the problem isn't rich people as
individuals but capitalism as a system
business owners learn to see everything
in terms of revenue and expenditure
taxes are an expense rent is an expense
raw materials and machines are expenses
and that means labor is also seen as
just another expense
human beings are reduced to numbers on a
spreadsheet that brings us to our next
point
capitalism doesn't care about human
well-being the primary concern of every
nation should be the well-being of its
citizens
but in modern hyper-capitalist countries
the only factor worth considering is the
almighty dollar
profit is the sole driver contrary to
what we're taught about classical
economics capitalism does not follow the
law of supply and demand
housing is in huge demand but it's not
profitable to supply
it so people go homeless as of 2019 the
us had a homeless population of nearly
600 000 people
we also have over 17 million vacant
homes
we could house nearly the entire
population of the new york metro area
that's the nearby cities in new york new
jersey and connecticut
but we won't house just 600 000 people
because it's not profitable
we'd rather let them die of exposure
because under capitalism
their lives have no inherent value and
remember those homelessness and empty
homes figures are from before the
pandemic
we currently have somewhere in the
ballpark of 50 million americans facing
eviction or foreclosure because of our
toxic system's inability to handle
crises like the coveted pandemic
this will never change unless we're able
to move beyond capitalism and assert
that
yes humans do have innate value beyond
what capitalists can extract from their
labor
and of course the problems at home pale
in comparison to how wealthy capitalist
nations treat the rest of the world
especially smaller or weaker nations
that we can bully just about every
instance of american foreign
intervention in the last 70 years has
been in the name of capital
whether we're securing oil fields
deposing leaders who want to escape the
stranglehold of imperial rule or
creating environments favorable to us
corporations
we're not afraid to use our military to
destabilize and destroy
other nations and regions in order to
make a quick buck the middle east is the
most recent example
we've been meddling in the middle east
for decades we entered iraq under false
pretenses
propagandizing the american population
with false intelligence reports
the global community knew that there
were no weapons of mass destruction in
iraq
but it sure made for convenient cover to
start a war that was unjustifiable
otherwise
the tendrils of capitalism don't stop at
the borders of our nation
they unjustly influence the daily lives
of innocent people around the world
not because america is necessarily evil
and wants to kill people
but because our capitalist system
demands it there is no alternative if we
want to maintain complete global
supremacy
okay so what's the alternative i know a
lot of people are frustrated that videos
like this don't often provide anything
beyond criticism of the current system
i'll do my best to explain why socialism
is a necessary next step
under capitalism your paycheck is made
as small as possible
unemployment is a positive for the
ruling class there being more empty
homes than homeless people is simply a
profitable housing market
automation leaves people without jobs
and healthcare is a luxury rather than a
human right
socialism turns all those negatives on
their head your paycheck is fairly
scaled in accordance with the quality
and quantity of your work
there's never a shortage of new jobs
homelessness can easily be eliminated
and automation allows people to spend
their time pursuing their actual
passions instead of toiling away in
factories
the struggling artists who wanted to
write symphonies but couldn't do to
their financial situation will now be
afforded the opportunity to pursue their
aspirations
it's like the american dream only real
the fundamental difference between
capitalism and socialism is that
capitalism puts the interest of the
market before the interest
of the people and socialism is just the
opposite one of the most fundamental
flaws of capitalism
including scandinavian social democracy
although it may seem like a nice
compromise between capitalism and
socialism
is that capitalism and markets
fundamentally rely on profit
every year a company's profit has to
increase every year a country's gdp has
to increase
forever and ever for the rest of time we
always have to keep growing
keep expanding our economies keep
building new factories keep producing
more consumer goods on an ever more
finite earth
infinite growth is a recipe for disaster
a disaster of which we're already seeing
the beginnings
not to mention the fact that we already
produce more than we need
the issue of poverty or homelessness or
starvation isn't that there's not enough
to go around
the issue isn't scarcity it's artificial
scarcity
we produce plenty but we don't
distribute to those in need
capitalism tells us that the market
follows the law of supply and demand
that the market is simply the most
efficient way of distributing goods to a
large number of people
but if that was the case then with our
current level of production we could
give
every human on the planet their own
house their own car
free access to education from
kindergarten to university and free
universal healthcare
we could do that at any time but we
actively choose not to
or rather jeff bezos and his ultra rich
buddies actively choose not to
jeff bezos has the power to end world
hunger on a whim
he wakes up every morning and makes the
decision not to if the thought even
crosses his mind at all
the world collectively produces enough
food to feed all of humanity
in fact the world produces more than
enough food and yet the number of people
undernourished in the world has been on
the rise since 2014
reaching an estimated 815 million in
2016.
rich countries not only have problems
with obesity but are also throwing away
metric tons of food every day
private corporations have deemed that
food which cannot be sold milk that's
out of date
tomatoes that aren't red or shiny enough
bananas that aren't crooked enough
is to be thrown into dumpsters and
bleach is to be poured on top so that
the hungry and homeless don't eat it
to not only deny food to the hungry when
you have plenty but to go
out of your way to ensure that the
hungry won't even eat your trash is a
barbaric and inhumane practice
under socialism all workers would be
allowed to reap what they sow
and receive according to the value of
the labor they put in as well as
democratically decide how the workplace
is run
the workers are the ones who produce
value they are the ones who should
receive the benefits
ceos and other corporate suits don't
contribute to the value produced by the
company
and yet they are paid hundreds of times
more for a worker to earn as much as a
ceo earns in a single year
they would have to work 45 years
socialism puts power
political social economic and financial
power in the hands of the 99
the proletariat normal people in such a
system
people are paid in accordance with the
quantity and quality of their work
workers are entitled to reap what they
sow to actually benefit from their hard
work
and isn't that what capitalists are
always telling us that hard work should
pay off
jeff bezos makes 321 million dollars a
day
someone who earns the federal minimum
wage earns 58
a day i do not believe that jeff bezos
works five and a half
million times harder than the average
minimum wage worker
frankly i think the average person works
far harder than mr amazon
if you're interested in what real
workplace democracy looks like worker
co-ops are a good place to start
they're not perfect but they're a
massive improvement on the average
predatory company
i made a video on the subject that you
can watch if you're interested
now as with any term that's been
hijacked by bad faith actors
there's a veritable mountain of
misconceptions that need to be addressed
covering all of them would take hours
but let's take a look at a few of the
more common ones
first let's consider the misguided
notion that free market policies make
poor countries rich
i think this is best summed up by hajun
chang author of 23 things they don't
tell you about capitalism
he says contrary to what is commonly
believed the performance of developing
countries in the period of state-led
development was superior to what they
have achieved during the subsequent
period of market-oriented reform
there were some spectacular failures of
state intervention but most of these
countries grew much faster with more
equitable income distribution and far
fewer financial crises during the bad
old days
than they have done in the period of
market-oriented reforms moreover
it is also not true that almost all rich
countries have become rich through free
market policies
the truth is more or less the opposite
with only a few exceptions
all of today's rich countries including
britain and the us
the supposed homes of free trade and
free market have become rich through the
combinations of protectionism
subsidies and other policies that today
they advise the developing countries not
to adopt
free market policies have made few
countries rich so far and will make few
rich in the future
23 things they don't tell you about
capitalism is a great book for someone
interested in ideas outside the scope of
usual capitalist economic teachings
but who isn't sure where they stand yet
it's also not entirely antagonistic to
the idea of capitalism
it's just willing to engage with the
reality of modern neoliberal capitalism
and its many problems
so even if you fancy yourself a
capitalist it's worth a read
i'll leave a link to check it out in the
description below next let's consider
the myth of the american dream
remember criticizing an economic system
is not an attack on the nation as a
whole or its people
we just need to engage with certain
realities of modern life under late
stage capitalism
when you hear the expression the
american dream you probably picture a
smiling family grilling in their
backyard behind a white picket fence
probably two kids and a dog it's a
pleasant picture
one of stability contentment and
fulfillment by definition
the american dream declares life should
be better and richer and fuller for
everyone
with opportunity for each according to
ability or achievement regardless of
social class or circumstances of birth
there was a time when the average
american could afford a home on a single
salary where we could afford to have
children
or a new car or pay our way through
school on a part-time wage
those days are long gone there are some
americans still living who experienced
that reality
and for them it's often difficult to
understand why younger generations seem
to have such a hard time when they were
able to thrive
world war ii catapulted the u.s to the
top of the global power rankings
the post-war years afforded many white
americans the prosperity we associate
with the image of the american dream
that period began over 70 years ago and
the following 20 or 30 years represented
the high water mark for american
prosperity
but as was inevitable the nature of
capitalism began to work against normal
people over the years
the average american's quality of life
and ability to afford luxuries
and eventually necessities has been on
the decline since at least the reagan
years
in the past a college degree all but
guaranteed you a job that paid well
enough to afford a home and support a
family on a single income
even those without college degrees could
land a job with a smile and a firm
handshake
and make far more adjusted for inflation
than workers today could ever dream of
today a college degree means next to
nothing as of early 2020
the unemployment rate for new graduates
exceeds that of the general population
among those that are employed 41 of them
are working jobs that don't require a
degree
i was one of those people i graduated
from a nice expensive school thanks to
the generosity of my parents
and i ended up selling cameras at best
buy the only reason i'm able to support
myself now is because i got lucky and
the youtube algorithm picked up my
channel one day
i now spend my time actively fighting
that same algorithm as it tries to bury
my content
even with my difficulties on this awful
platform i'm still far better off than
most of my friends working traditional
jobs
my position is not unique the only
people i know who are able to achieve
what could be considered a modern
american dream
are other youtubers and people in
non-traditional jobs but that's not the
american dream is it
the american dream is supposed to be for
all of us not just a lucky few
if you accept a position in a typical
american company you will not be able to
live the life your grandparents did or
even your parents
supporting a family on a single income
is unfathomable
paying for healthcare on the market is
unfathomable even affording the bare
essentials like food and rent is
becoming a real challenge for millions
of americans
the american dream died a long time ago
long before most people watching this
video were born
that's not to say we can't reignite that
possibility but we need to acknowledge
that it doesn't exist now
and it will never be possible again
under capitalism
finally let's tackle perhaps the biggest
misconception of all
socialism has never worked this one
comes up in every single conversation
about capitalism
whether you're advocating for socialism
or not it's a knee-jerk bit of
propaganda that most americans have
swallowed hook line and sinker
first we need to realize that socialism
like any system
is a spectrum you can implement
socialist policies in capitalist
countries and vice versa
to say socialism has never worked is
just as silly as saying capitalism has
never worked
but let's look at a few specifics we'll
start with bolivia
if you're an american the most you've
probably heard about bolivia is that
their former leader evo morales was some
kind of horrible dictator
as usual this is anti-left propaganda
morale served as bolivia's 65th
president
and its first indigenous president from
2006 to 2013.
he was democratically elected and well
loved by the general population
he is not well loved by the united
states why
because he's a socialist and he tried to
free bolivia from u.s influence and the
control of multinational corporations
during his terms morales worked to
improve the lives of bolivia's poor
more equally distribute national gas
profits and introduce programs to combat
illiteracy
poverty racism and sexism these strong
socialist policies led to a period of
notable economic growth
as well as a reduction in poverty
morales is regarded by many with the
exception of the us
as a champion of democratic reforms
common sense policy
anti-imperialism environmentalism and
genuine care for the poor and working
families
he objectively improved the lives of his
people to the u.s
he's a big scary dictator then there's
burkina faso under the leadership of
thomas senkara
sankara assumed office at 33 having led
a popular movement to overthrow the
dominance of french colonial power
as a marxist revolutionary sankara was
deeply concerned with the health and
well-being of the people of burkina faso
immediately upon taking office he
launched a massive campaign to feed
house and provide medical care for the
entire population he followed this with
a large-scale vaccination program to
eliminate polio meningitis and measles
vaccinating two and a half million
people in a single week
earning the praise of the world health
organization as far as foreign policy
was concerned the cenkara administration
was staunchly anti-imperialist
and focused on agrarian reform to
prevent famine instead of relying on
foreign aid
they prioritized strong education and
planted over 10 million trees to stop
desertification
in environmentally threatened areas
sankara appointed women to high
government positions and encouraged them
to work outside the home in an attempt
to reform outdated patriarchal notions
he also had the integrity to lead by
example only accepting a military
officer's salary
and redirecting the presidential salary
to an orphan fund thomas sankara's
socialist policies did more to improve
the lives of his people in a few short
years than most nations do in a hundred
poverty was reduced hunger and famine
were reduced preventable diseases were
essentially eliminated
education and literacy rates went
through the roof environmental concerns
were addressed and
imperialism's hold on the nation was
diminished what did sankara get for his
efforts
he was overthrown and murdered by french
colonial sympathizers
there are so many examples of socialist
policies being implemented with great
success around the world
and for each of them the story ends the
same way a coup
an assassination a fabricated war or
american intervention
when people say socialism has never
worked what they should really say
is capitalist powers have never allowed
socialism to continue working
these socialist policies do work they
are incredibly popular with the general
population of each country in which
they're implemented
and they always produce outcomes that
put wealthy capitalist nations to shame
until of course we come in and destroy
everything they've worked so hard to
build
why do we do it because the united
states can't stand the thought of people
getting a glimpse of what life could be
like under a more progressive humane and
common sense system
so let's wrap this up if you're an
american like i am
you live in the richest most powerful
nation in the history of the world
we have almost endless resources that
could be used to solve any problem that
we face
we could fund universal healthcare which
would even save us money
we could fund climate change mitigation
measures we could fund free higher
education
better infrastructure public
transportation we could end homelessness
build state-of-the-art schools libraries
parks and hospitals
we could ensure every american worker is
compensated fairly for their work
we could have the american dream instead
all that money goes to the military to
fund intervention in other countries
it goes to tax breaks for corporations
it goes to bailing out criminal
industries that destroy the planet and
the lives of countless human beings
marxism socialism communism pick
whichever scary word you want
they represent the rejection of our
dystopian state of affairs
they stand for the expansion of human
freedom for the acknowledgment of
universal rights
for kindness decency and care for the
less fortunate
an america that embraced at least some
of the tenants of marxism would be a
nation that didn't destroy the lives of
innocent people the world over
it would be a nation that cared for its
own that addressed the material concerns
of the many over the greedy demands of
the few
it would be a nation that could truly
lead the way into the future a future
that is bright
just and righteous
this video would not have been possible
without the collaboration and insight of
azure scapegoat
they've just uploaded their own
companion video on capitalism and
alienation
i highly recommend you check out their
episode by following this link
they have all sorts of videos with the
same sharp criticism and perspective you
just saw here
i've left links to all their social
media in the description below help
support marxist voices by subscribing or
joining their patreon
every dollar helps keep the lights on so
channels like ours can keep producing
content to counter the mainstream
narrative
if you're a leftist channel and you'd
like to collaborate send me an email at
secondthoughtchannel gmail.com
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes if you hated it go ahead and
drop a thumbs down
you can check out my previous episodes
by clicking the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you